I work out in the middle school where I
see teachers day in and day out
praise the left this way of thinking and
bash the conservative way of thinking
and I just want to know what you suggest
I would do to not necessarily promote
conservative but conservatism but to
just kind of keep a objective like
viewpoint with teaching the kids I mean
so I think that the the question is sort
of two-part even though it really isn't
the the first part is how do you do the
second and fired right I mean that's
that really is the question one of the
big problems is the public school level
is that it in in California you have to
be a member of the teachers union to
teach in a public school and that's a
disaster because the teachers unions are
really discriminatory against people on
the right and they obviously take all
your money and they spend on leftist
politicians like Jerry Brown and it's an
serious problem yeah that's a question
you're gonna have to decide yourself how
far you can you go without getting fired
as far as what you can say to the kids I
think that it's perfectly fine to say
here's an argument I heard one of your
other teachers making today it's a valid
argument let me explain where I think
it's mistaken and if the other teacher
is a problem with that then let them
talk with you about it in front of the
class like this idea that you get a free
feel to say whatever you want in a
classroom without ever being
contradicted I think is incredibly
stupid and I think it's damaging to the
kids because especially
honestly I think that one of the reasons
that the left is is actually vulnerable
on campus even though they seem
invulnerable on campus and this is true
in high schools and junior High's as
well they never hear a good position on
the rights when they finally hear a good
position on the right a lot of them are
convinced because they've never actually
had to deal with those ideas before if
they had deals with these ideas and
actually debate for themselves whether
they're true or not they get a better
perspective on where maybe they actually
stand so I would just suggest like
really going directly at it and saying
you know you may have heard from your
teacher this here's the counselor
perspective you can believe that other
teacher but here's the counter
perspective in the data to back it up